une ambiance des grands jours ce samedi
29 avril au stade maubouron de
Versailles le Racing Club de France
deuxième de National 2 recevait le
leader Rouen des milliers de supporters
ont répondu présent pour soutenir leur
protéger un premier contre le deuxième
de base et puis le Racing 5 club
historique c'est normal il faut que
l'ambiance ah là c'est exceptionnel
c'est la première fois qu'on rame tout
autant de monde franchement ça va être
un match de fou là c'est une finale là
c'est clairement une fin
dans cette ambiance de feu les deux
équipes tentent de marquer mais ne
trouve pas la faille dans cette première
période le score à la pose
00 la première période elle était
c'était très très serrée c'était un
match vraiment fermé les deux équipes
étaient très bien en place donc il y
avait pas il y avait pas beaucoup
d'espace voilà on le savait on savait
que ça allait être un match compliqué en
seconde période le match ne s'emballe
pas le Racing aurait peut-être pu
bénéficier d'un penalty sur cette action
mais l'arbitre ne dis rien en fin de
match les joueurs locaux pensent
arracher la victoire sur cette frappe
mais les filets ne trembleront pas score
final 0 à 0 un résultat qui arrangeront
les Normands restent leaders je pense
qu'il y avait la place notamment sur la
deuxième mi-temps où il y avait
plusieurs situations on aurait dû mieux
jouer le coup et il y en avait la
possibilité de pouvoir
voilà pourra ouvrir le score après
l'Euro ils étaient venus pour chercher
au minimum un match nul donc ils sont
pas beaucoup livrés vous voyez sur la
fin il s'est gagné du temps sur les
touches sur les dégagements voilà on
sentait que le match nul c'était c'était
ce qui cherchait tout n'est pas perdu
pour le Racing Club de France il reste
quatre matchs d'ici la fin de la saison
pour accrocher la première place la
prochaine rencontre est programmée ce
samedi 6 mai sur le terrain de
Saint-Malo
[Musique]